today on the matt walsh show desperate
democrats grasping for
any reason to hate amy coney barrett
have now decided that her use of the
term sexual preference is offensive and
horrible
uh the entire left decided in the span
of 24 hours that this term is offensive
we'll talk about the implications of
living in a culture where words
change meaning so quickly and also why
the left's
theory of sexual orientation completely
contradicts their theories of gender
so that's we'll discuss all of that also
five headlines including a new biden had
reaching out to black voters that is
without exaggeration the most
patronizing and degrading political ad i
think i've ever seen and we'll play it
for you and in our daily cancellation
the nba is canceled not just by me this
is a decision we all have made and for
good reason i think
so we'll discuss that too all that
coming up but first let's talk about
light stream
now i think many of us can say that we
have interest rates that
on our credit cards uh that are higher
than we prefer we carry the balance on
the cards and we're losing money by the
second with the interest rates
that's why you need light stream light
stream offers credit card consolidation
loans with five
from 5.95 apr with auto pay and
excellent credit
the rate is fixed so it will never go up
over the life of loan and the
application is 100 online you don't have
to leave your house you don't have to
put on pants it's great you can get a
loan from 5 000 to 100 000 and there are
absolutely no
fees like i think debt is a problem for
a lot of us and i've seen it really
prevent people from moving on with their
lives and careers
don't let that happen to you there's no
reason for it my listeners can save even
more with an additional interest rate
discount
the only way to get this discount is to
go to lightstream.com
walsh l-i-g-h-t-s-t-r-e-a-m
slash walsh subject to credit approval
rate includes 0.5
auto pay discount lowest rate requires
excellent credit terms and conditions
apply and offers are subject to change
without notice visit lightstream.com
walsh for more information
well you know it's immensely tempting to
say that
democrat senators questioning amy coney
barrett during her confirmation hearings
this week are engaging in quite a lot of
mansplaining the con the condescension
is there the unnecessary
long-winded lectures the interruptions
they're even using poster boards and
other visual aids to get their points
across
the only reason i won't call any of this
man's planning is that the term is vapid
and stupid and used
used unironically only by people whose
minds have been warped
by politics and ideology still by the
left's rules
applied equitably as they like to say it
must be concluded that barrett's
inquisitors
are sexist bullies even the women who
are apparently infected with
internalized misogyny or some such
nonsense
but if the meaning and application of
mansplaining changes according to the
political needs of the moment at least
the word is contrived and meaningless
from the start
the left invented that term i suppose
they could do whatever they want with it
the far more disturbing thing is to
witness how real words
words that existed before our era of
woke politics are now redefined with
rapid speed on the fly
and with coordinated efficiency the
hearings have provided us with perhaps
the most glaring
and most striking example of the left's
language manipulation scheme
that we've seen yet and we talked about
the game they're playing with the term
court packing already
but this is this is way worse than that
so on tuesday morning
as you ate your breakfast burrito the
term sexual preference
was perfectly normal perfectly
acceptable
perfectly common and if you used it
anywhere
everyone would know what you meant and
almost nobody would think to be offended
by it
by bedtime as you crawled beneath your
covers sexual preference had become an
unspeakable slur
in the span of 18 hours this new meaning
had been adopted by the media
politicians even the dictionary itself
anyone who wasn't paying attention to
the news on wednesday will no doubt use
this
newly minted gay slur at some point in
the future and be utterly
baffled and horrified by the looks and
breathless chastisements that follow
that of course is part of the plan so
how did this happen
during the course of the confirmation
hearings early on uh tuesday
amy cody barrett responded to a question
about gay rights
and and she said that she would quote
never discriminate on the basis of
sexual preference
uh here she is in her own words listen i
do want to be clear that i
have never discriminated on the basis of
sexual preference
and would not ever discriminate on the
basis of sexual preference
you know like racism i think
discrimination is important
gasp shocking well not really
to most observers this seems like a
totally normal statement
hardly noteworthy but some on the left
sensing that barrett would give them few
opportunities to be offended
decided to make do with what they had so
leftist twitter accounts began
setting the stage claiming that the
judge's use of the term sexual
preference
is somehow abhorrent all of a sudden it
wasn't before it is now
kyle griffin an msnbc producer with
almost a million followers
was early on the bandwagon tweeting
sexual preference a term used by justice
barrett is offensive and outdated
the term implies sexuality is a choice
it is not
news organizations should not repeat
justice barrett's words without
providing that that important context
various others joined the chorus
eventually they seem to have attracted
the attention of senator maisie hirono
who leapt into action that evening
hirono circled back
to scold barrett calling her choice of
language offensive and outdated
repeating kyle griffin's tweet verbatim
she then explained that only quote
anti-lgbtq
activists use the term because they want
to suggest that sexual orientation is a
choice when in fact says hirono
it is a key part of an individual
individual's identity and it is
she says immutable listen
this morning senator feinstein asked
your question about the supreme court's
2015 decision and no burgerfeld the
hodges the case in which the court
recognized the constitutional
right to same-sex marriage and i was
disappointed that you wouldn't give a
direct answer whether you're agreed
with the majority in that case or if you
instead agree with your mentor
justice scalia that no such right exists
in the constitution
so even though you didn't give a direct
answer i think your response did
speak volumes not once but twice
you use the term sexual preference
to describe those in the lgbtq community
and let me make clear sexual preference
is an offensive and outdated term
it is used by anti-lgbtq activists
to suggest that sexual orientation is a
choice
it is not sexual orientation is a key
part
of a person's identity that sexual
orientation is both a normal expression
of human sexuality and
immutable was a key part
of the majority's opinion in a burgerfel
which by the way scalia did not agree
with
so if it is your view that sexual
orientation is merely a preference
as you noted then the lgbtq community
should be
rightly concerned whether you would
uphold their constitutional
right to marry and then expectedly cory
booker
never missing an opportunity to
grandstand also jumped in to register
his objection to the term judge barrett
uh five years ago
the supreme court ruled that the
constitution protects the rights of
same-sex couples to marry
this was a burgerful case which has been
discussed today the court declared
the constitution grants lgbtq americans
equal dignity in the eyes of the law
hundreds of thousands of couples have
built their lives on this decision
i've married some of them myself on that
day five years ago the court fulfilled
really that ideal
of equal justice under law and yet now
the same-sex marriage is legal we've
seen efforts to try to undermine that
decision
justice ginsburg wrote about legal rules
that would quote create two kinds of
marriage full marriage and skim milk
marriage
i firmly believe that our laws shouldn't
allow discrimination against people
on the basis of who they are i have a
number of questions on this topic if i
can get through them
but i wanted to offer you a further
opportunity to address the issue
that i don't think you got to fully
address that my colleague brought up
when you did use the term sexual
preference earlier today
rather than sexual orientation is there
a difference and what is it
senator i really and using that word do
not mean to
imply that i think that you know
that it's a matter not a matter of that
it's not an immutable characteristic or
that it's solely a matter of preference
i honestly did not mean any offense or
to make any statement by that but by
what you just said you understand about
that immutable characteristic in other
words
that one's uh sexuality is not a
preference it is
who they are is that what you're saying
senator i'm saying i was not trying to
make any comment on it i fully respect
all the rights of the lgbt community
a booger file is an important precedent
of the court
i reject any kind of discrimination
on any sort of basis and then it was off
to the races
slate jezebel vox other outlets all
joined the dog pile publishing articles
condemning
sexual preference as offensive degrading
bigoted
a dog whistle we must say orientation
not preference they all suddenly agreed
our sexuality is
is not a preference uh it is ingrained
it is fundamental it is
an unchangeable part of our essence as
human beings
and to cap it all off webster's online
dictionary changed its definition of the
word preference
at the end of the night to note that it
is offensive when applied to sexuality
now of course dictionary definitions
change to reflect evolving meanings and
common usages and that's fine
but the usage and meaning of preference
has not evolved
the left to include now the dictionary
is not merely
noting a change in common usage but
trying to effect a change
by pretending that his that it has
already occurred
words evolve gradually and organically
over many years
changes in language in our society are
rather than gradual and organic
sudden artificial orchestrated
ideological
and this is a very different sort of
thing
now it's probably no use to point this
out but many of the people
and and media outlets lambasting barrett
for her use of sexual preference
have themselves uttered or written it
many times over the years
the advocate for example blasted the
anti-lgbtq plus
language only two weeks after publishing
an article
that makes uncritical use of that same
term
slate professed to be so alarmed by
barrett's language
after years of using the exact same
language in its articles
indeed just this year slate's advice
column featured a question
from a 65 year old straight man
wondering if his quote
sexual preference may have changed over
time
uh as as he finds himself fantasizing
about men and he decided to write slate
about this
the response from slate writer rich
juzwiak
certainly does not sound consistent with
sexual orientation as an immutable
characteristic this is what he says
quote from slate some people keep
evolving sexually finding different
things they're into at different times
in an episode of netflix's sex explained
fantasies are
compared to language research suggests
we don't unlearn
old ones but we can learn new ones dr
justin lay
miller who has studied fantasies
extensively
okay suggests that one way of picking up
new sexual interests would be
exposure via porn for example to
something novel when on the brink of
orgasm
for many that's when the disgust
response is reduced
the ensuing orgasm could prompt the
stimulus to be sought again
and a new fantasy slash kink is is born
okay that's slight
evolving sexually new sexual interests
a new fantasy is born this makes sexual
orientation sound an
awful lot like a preference that can be
changed
and in many cases does change there are
many real world examples of this
happening
slate itself provided one of them sexual
orientation is immutable
is dogma impotently asserting itself
against the reality that clearly
contradicts and disproves it
besides there is an inescapable logical
problem
for adherence to left-wing gender theory
who also claim
sexual orientation as ingrained and
unchangeable the problem is that
their their gender theories cannot
coexist
with their theory of sexual orientation
these are mutually exclusive
propositions
for reasons that should be obvious take
the example of a gay man who transitions
into a woman
if he is really a woman now he is no
longer gay
thus sexual orientation can change if he
must always be gay because orientation
is immutable he must always be a man
there is no way around this without
undermining or denying
his self-identity somewhere along the
timeline in order to make bro
both propositions work you must point to
this individual and say that he was
wrong about being gay or wrong about
being a man or he's wrong about being a
woman now
but that is to claim that it's possible
for a person to be wrong about their own
self-identity
which would cause the whole artifice of
left-wing gender theory to collapse
the scheme doesn't work if outsiders are
able to judge a person's identity as
incorrect
based on our own logical or physical
observations
this is a problem that cannot be
overcome
though it can be blithely ignored the
advantage after all being a relativist
is that you get to invent your own truth
to suit the moment
different moments call for different
truths the relativist feels no need to
maintain any common logical thread from
one moment to the next
now you may say that this is also the
hallmark of insanity
and you would be correct but insanity as
we have discovered is our culture's most
powerful
political ideology let's get to our five
[Music]
headlines
you know nothing beats a good
comfortable sofa as far as i'm concerned
this is argument i have with my wife all
the time because she when it comes to
sofas a lot of times she's looking for
uh style over comfort and my point is
you know it's really more of a comfort
thing it doesn't matter what the what
the sofa looks like
we have to sit in it we're not looking
at it it's got to be comfortable
well what if you could have both what if
you could have a a sofa that looks great
and is also very comfortable
that's where um all form comes in you
know if you've been listening to the
show for a while you've probably heard
me talk about helix mattress
which which helix mattresses are or you
know you want to talk about style and
comfort very very comfortable
well helix has left the bedroom and
started making sofa they've uh sofas
they've just launched
a new company called all form and
they're already making the best sofas
we've ever seen or or sat on so what
makes an all-form sofa really cool for
starters it's the easiest way you can
customize a sofa using premium materials
and at a fraction of the cost of
traditional sofas
you can pick your fabric the sofa color
the color of the leg sofa size
you can shape everything to your exact
specifications they've got arm chairs
and love seats all the way up to an
eight seat sectional
so there's something there for everyone
all form sofas are also
delivered directly to your home with
fast free shipping you know in the past
if you want to order a sofa it could
take
weeks or even months to arrive and you
would need someone to come and assemble
a thing for you at your house i've been
through that before it's not fun
all form takes just three to seven days
to arrive in the mail and you can
assemble it yourself in a few minutes no
tools needed it's just that simple
um this is and the other thing if you go
to the all forum website which i've been
on
very easy to navigate and you just you
put yourself it's a lot of fun you put
put together the sofa you want
and you can have one that looks great
and is real comfortable to sit in if
getting a sofa without trying trying it
in store sounds a little risky you don't
need to worry
you get 100 days to decide if you want
to keep it i think that's enough time
uh that's more than three months and if
you don't love it which i think you will
anyway but if you don't love it
they'll pick it up for free and you'll
get a full refund it's that simple they
even offer a forever warranty literally
forever there's a warranty on this thing
to find your perfect sofa check out
allforum.com
walsh and all form is offering 20 off
all orders for our listeners if you go
now allform.com
walsh okay um
where are we let's find our headlines
here if i can
let's see okay good big report here in
the daily wire says newly published
emails allegedly show that democrat
presidential candidate
uh joe biden's son hunter biden
leveraged his relationship with his
father
then vice president biden to increase
his pay at ukrainian
gas company burisma the email comes from
a laptop computer that was dropped off
at a computer repair store last april in
biden's home state of delaware
the person who brought the laptop into
the store never paid for service never
retrieved the device
federal law enforcement officials
reportedly seized the laptop in december
after the store owner alerted them to it
but not before the store owner made a
copy of the hard drive
the new york post which was given a copy
of the hard drive on sunday reported
quote
hunter biden discussed leveraging his
connection to his father in a bid to
boost his pay from a ukrainian national
gas
natural gas company uh in a lengthy memo
to his
then business partner devon archer who
already sat on burisma board
biden repeatedly mentioned my guy while
apparently referring to then vice
president
joe biden under president barack obama
the elder biden was the point person for
u.s
policy towards ukraine and held a press
conference there with prime minister
uh the prime minister on april 22 um
and then it goes into the specific you
could read the the new york post report
but it goes into
uh some of the examples quoting quoting
from these alleged emails
sounds to me like i don't know a massive
scandal but
the deflating thing is that political
scandals are of course meaningless if
they aren't reported
for this to do any damage against biden
it would need to
be reported by more than just fox news
and the new york post
um and us it would need to be reported
in the mass media
which it won't be of course so you want
to talk about influencing elections
while the mainstream media refusing to
cover massive scandals when they pertain
to one particular candidate
that is certainly one way to influence
an election and that is also
most of the time the essence of fake
news i say this all the time
fake news is is usually not
inventing stories that's that's not
generally how fake news works
fake news is in the stories they choose
not to cover
it's in pretending that something isn't
news
that's the fake news part most of the
time all right joe biden is continuing
his outreach to black voters
and as is often the case when white
democrats reach out to black voters
the results are pretty patronizing um
and he you have to just hear this to
believe it this is the biden ad on his
youtube page
featuring two guys having a rap battle
where they discuss joe biden's policies
in the rap battle take a listen
yo why you ain't been answering your
phone you know why i'm calling you
you have to vote you know why i don't
vote
because as a black man i just feel like
there's no hope
our president telling people to go back
to china
taking the coronavirus as a joke and
that's the part
that frightened me when you choose a
president it's supposed to be a knockout
then while this situation doesn't entice
me if you got the answers to get me out
this dark path my brother
enlighten me we always telling each
other to stay woke
that's why this time we gotta use our
voice and you have to vote
the fact should show biden has a plan
for african americans
we're not dealing with your average joe
i see the way you're looking right now
you know exactly where i'm gonna go with
this
for four years we had trump in office
and we made the most of it
but we finally got somebody that could
be in office that can give us a chance
to have home ownership
i'm talking to all of you 640 billion
dollars
over the course of 10 years so we can
finally get house and that's affordable
okay a couple of things here first of
all
you have here in this ad two black men
on a basketball court having a
conversation
through rapping if this isn't the most
stereotypical
and insulting political ad we've seen in
decades i don't know what is what
what what would you what earns that
title if not what you just
heard right there second um
you know maybe beside the point but the
freestyle most of what you just heard
there didn't even rhyme
so he says uh but we finally got
somebody that could be in office that
can finally give us the chance to have
home ownership
i'm talking to all of you 640 billion
dollars over the course of 10 years
so we finally get housing that's
affordable that's not
it doesn't rhyme that's isn't a wrap
supposed to run if you don't have
music and uh if there's no background
music
and it doesn't rhyme then that's just
norm that's just speaking all you you're
speaking is what you're doing
you're just speaking with hand gestures
so i mean by i guess i'm i freestyle all
the time i guess
i freestyle at my house to my wife
i already took the trash out please stop
asking me
that was my freestyle i just uh i
dropped a bar right there
as the kids say is that what you do you
drop the bars
spit the bar how does it go i don't know
uh so that that's man that's
that's crazy that's we've done the
cringe challenge before
try to get through that whole video
that's like four minutes i think the
whole thing
i played 30 seconds of it so see if you
can get through the whole four minutes
it's difficult all right um boycott nbc
is currently trending
uh it's the we've got another boycott
going and
the reason is even dumber than than you
think the
reasons are always dumb for boycotts
most of the time uh but this the reason
is
they're boycotting nbc the left is
because they're having uh
nbc's having a town hall with trump
which will run opposite of a different
town hall on abc with biden
and so that's the reason for the boycott
this is bad
because well the reason the real reason
it's bad is because it involves trump
and so that's why it's bad
but the reason they're giving is that um
if if you do both town halls at the same
time
people won't be able to watch both and
so
this is really a form of voter
suppression because the voters are not
able to inform themselves because you
got both town halls going on at the same
time
and that's a reason to uh to boycott
yeah well the problem is for one thing
who the hell actually wants to watch
either of these town halls let alone
both of them who would willingly sit
and watch a politician's town hall for
fun
and second point do you not have dvr is
there anybody left in america
who doesn't have the capability to
digitally record programming
and even if you don't don't you have the
internet you can if you're boycotting if
you're if you're hashtag boycott nbc you
probably have the internet you can go on
and find the
the clip of it later and watch if you
really want to so obviously a very
stupid reason for a boycott
number four more big news here oreo is
defeating discrimination
by releasing a rainbow-colored cookie
i feel like they've done this before
maybe i'm wrong but
either way remarkable just uh
all you can do is marvel at the courage
and boldness
to have this rainbow colored cookie and
the good thing is
whatever distracts them from making more
double stuffed oreos
like that's good to me if they focus
their energy on making the
rainbow oreos instead of the double
stuffed
i i consider that a win because double
stuffed oreos are disgusting
and i say that as a loyal oreo eater
going back decades
the problem with the double stuffed oreo
is that you know when when you have that
much of the cream
you start to realize that the cream is
not really cream it's some sort of
hideous synthetic goop it's really the
same problem with the quarter pounder at
mcdonald's i think
like the big mac is great because it's
mostly just bread and
and the sauce with two little slivers of
of
would-be meat but then you get the
bigger cut of the meat and it becomes
obvious that this is not meat but rather
salty greasy styrofoam
so it really becomes too much of a good
thing why are we talking about this i
forget oh yeah rainbow colored oreos so
there you go
five finally um more big news an
innovation
almost as impressive as the rainbow
colored oreo
the iphone 12 uh was unveiled yesterday
moment we've been waiting for here it is
you can look at it right here
uh spinning around and dancing for you
so there it is it so it's it's you know
you look at that you think
well it's a lot like the iphone 11 and
the iphone 10
and the iphone 9 8 7 6 5 4 3 two one
very similar to that except this time
with more cameras
this is all they're doing now with the
iphones i guess they're just they've run
out of ideas
they just add new cameras each time
every every successive iphone from now
on there's just another
camera there on the thing is pock marked
with cameras at this point
and uh all of this camera technology
only so that narcissists can take
clearer pictures of their own ugly
faces that's all anybody uses it for
anyway
pretty soon it's gonna be you know like
pretty soon it's just gonna it's gonna
be just a camera i think that that's
where we're headed that the phones
we're gonna we're sort of transitioning
back we're going full circle
and by the iphone 20 it'll be just a
polaroid camera
dancing around there on the screen for
you personally i would like a phone
here's my crazy idea um
i would like a phone that's a phone
and also has the internet i like the
internet part of it so just a phone with
the internet that's all i need i don't
need anything else
and and also this would be the advantage
you don't have any of the other
technology
uh then it also maybe will have a
battery that lasts more than 14 seconds
that's my dream that's what i'm waiting
for
because the problem is that with all
this new technology added you need more
power so that so that now you have to
like plug your iphone directly into the
core of the earth
in order to get a charge that lasts even
you know a few hours
so that's what i would like to see
battery life
internet phone text message that's all i
need i'm a simple man
okay we're gonna get to our daily
cancellation in just a second
but first we've been telling you about
uh daily wire's old glory
baseball bat which is back if you
haven't gotten yours yet you got to do
that this is our limited edition
handcrafted custom painted baseball bat
emblazoned with the daily wire logo and
since we relaunched on monday they've
almost sold out again
today is the last day they'll be
available so you can still get yours if
you hurry
text the keyword baseball to 83400 to
purchase
your bat today all right time for our
daily cancellation so today i'm
canceling the nba
um well i'm not really canceling them or
or
it isn't just me this is a democratic
cancellation we have canceled the nba
together
i think for me i'm just sort of a
typical case
probably i never qualified as a diehard
nba fan to begin with
but i did enjoy the sport and typically
became more invested during the playoffs
i loved watching the nba finals
especially and had missed
probably very few nba finals in the past
decade or so
i never had a home team but i rooted for
my favorite players
i had followed lebron james's career in
particular since his first stint with
the cleveland cavaliers
but i didn't watch a single minute of
this past nba season which just
concluded
lebron and the lakers won the trophy on
sunday i didn't realize the game was
even happening or that the lakers were
up in the series i didn't know anything
about it
i found out the next day due to the
viral footage of
lakers fans rioting and celebration
because again apparently
revelers celebrating a basketball team's
victory are immune to covid just like
blm activists and
attendees of memorial services for
democrats all of them are immune
very very fascinating science so this
was the first nba season that i've ever
ignored and
i have to tell you i didn't miss it
being a sports fan is like being under
some sort of trance
you care immensely about this thing for
reasons you can't quite explain
but if the spell breaks and you stop
caring
you'll wonder why you ever did or why
you should start again
so for me the the spell broke because of
the nba's ceaseless political
propagandizing
too aggressive too wearying too
irritating just too much
this sort of thing may be tolerable up
to a certain line i'm not sure where
that line is exactly
but it has surely been crossed when a
league canonizes an accused rapist and
serial abuser like
jacob blake and its top star tries to
foment more division and chaos by
telling wild tales about racist cops
hunting black men and nearly all the
players and coaches decide to turn the
national anthem into a forum for
self-aggrandizing political stunts
that that's you cross the line i can
deal with little a little bit of
politics from professional athletes
but if getting smacked in the face with
an ideological 2x4 is the price of
admission
i'd rather just go do something else
with my time
and i'm not alone according to nielsen
this was the lowest rated mba finals in
40 years
a mere 5.6 million viewers tuned in to
watch the game
that i didn't know was even being played
to put that in
put that in perspective perspective
double that number watched a regular
season
sunday night football matchup on the
same night game six of the finals last
year had three times the viewership
back in the michael jordan era in the
90s the championship round would
routinely draw
four five six times as many viewers
there's no mystery about why people are
tuning out now some in the sports world
have tried to rescue
the nba from the consequences of its own
politicizing claiming that viewership is
down
because of other things like kovid you
know for example yahoo sports
published an article yesterday arguing
that the ratings decline
suffered by other professional sports
leagues like the nfl and mlb
prove that politics can't be the driving
factor but
other professional sports leagues like
the nfl mlb have also engaged in
political sermonizing to one degree or
another
if the nba is being hit especially hard
it's because they've been especially
loud while screeching from their soapbox
besides just ask the fans why they're
turning away they'll tell you
there was one poll done recently has
nearly 40 percent
watching fewer games because of
politicization and that poll
separately counts uh the fans who've
switched off because of the nba's
dealings with china
so china hypocrisy and political
posturing which are two very
interconnected issues
together account for almost 60 percent
of fans
these are not small numbers this is not
a small problem for the nba
now it's probably true that covid isn't
helping matters
the absence of fans does tend to make
the games less exciting
even without all the social justice
stuff but kovid the election the riots
all of the other unpleasant and
worrisome subjects dominating the news
are major reasons why so many americans
would like to turn to sports for an
escape and major reasons why
we have little interest in our sports
escapism being served to us with a side
of left-wing moralizing
it's like it's like you know going to
chuck e cheese as a child
only to be told that you can't jump in
the ball pit or go on the jungle gym
until you complete your multiplication
tables and finish a plate of brussels
sprouts
you know chuck e cheese exists precisely
to be a place
where multiplication tables and brussels
sprouts don't exist
you have defeated the purpose by
combining these two universes
now granted that may not be the best
analogy because vegetables and
mathematics are good for you even if you
don't like them
blm talking points on the other hand
promoted so relentlessly by the nba
are not good or true or healthy or
helpful in any way
it's just that when we turn on the news
or we enter into a political debate with
someone
we're prepared to encounter and engage
with
that kind of rhetoric they're part of
the bargain
they should not be need not be part of
the sports bargain
which makes our tolerance in that
setting much lower
we would rather sit and watch the game
enjoy the sport for its own sake
focus on a fun and frivolous and
pointless thing for a while
and that's it and if that's too much to
ask so be it we'll turn the tv off
and turn our energies elsewhere and you
know
it's probably for the best on second
thought
so the nba is uh really just
canceled as i said i'm not the one doing
it they've they've just been canceled
and it honestly is like a trance because
once
once once you just say okay i don't want
to watch this anymore
and then you look back and you think
what why was i even watching it to begin
with
in what way is my life you know my life
now without watching the nba
playoffs especially in what way has it
been
harmed is my life am i am i worse off
now without this in my life no i'm not
in fact i just have more time to do
other things of course i end up wasting
that time too but still
i can waste it in other potentially more
fruitful ways
so that's why the nba is canceled and
that's going to do it for us today
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening
godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio was mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing
the end of days is approaching and the
moon is turned to blood but on the
andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew claven
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
clayton